how come you never
ever hear anyone say yeah i kind of
regret having kids a little bit they do
like
never [ __ ] tell you oh yeah
[Music]
welcome back to big mood thank you so
much for tuning in we love you
today we have
nikki
uh hi it's gina and jess and tim
thanks for uh being here with us and
today we're gonna get
maybe a little deep what's up 20 22 now
starting 2022 off with a bang
did you miss us oh my god you missed us
if anyone's wondering that's on audio
i'm dressed like christmas in miami so
yeah you're welcome black turtleneck
long sleeve yeah i wish we had some
cuban links for you guys cuban cuban hat
yes
i'm still in thanksgiving i think yeah
yeah you're a little late to the party
stuck anyway back to the topic at hand
so today we're talking about
um so there was this question posted on
reddit it says therapist what is
something people tell you that they are
ashamed of but it's actually normal
that's a pretty good time what's normal
i'm triggered
that's actually the first one
no no so like for example like a
therapist uh the way that they start
this off is they're saying that
therapists told me wondering if you're
normal is one of the most normal oh it
is common things a person can question i
don't think there's a normal i think
it's just like a societal standard
and they were set in place a long time
ago and we all thought we had to conform
to it i think i guess common would be
more people want to know like if they're
the odd one out but it's funny because
everyone's the star of their own show so
they think they're the odd one out and
they're like their story is so special
or their thing is so weird or they're
thinking there's no typical and
neurodiverse yeah so there are like
different ways that your brains are
wired yeah i can understand i think the
most mentally stable people that i'm so
jealous of are the pumpkin spice latte
[ __ ] you know what those people you
sure no no no no no no no no no let me
explain let me see
if you're misunderstanding my pleasure i
don't know what it is but these [ __ ]
like the veil they're the types that
have the laundry room and instead of
just having the detergent in the plastic
bins it comes from they put in the glass
and they decanter their the detergents
and stuff actually and like their houses
are decorated okay
they're totally decorated their hair is
always curled i'm a black coffee drinker
i think you got it wrong okay maybe i
don't know and they're different
they're always into cabbage
they have a golden retriever named
cooper always you know the more i don't
know they seem like they're organized
and like they're like i love jason the
less sex you're having they're just
stay-at-home moms they're organized they
just have time for that [ __ ] they seem
they seem to have their life together
they seem as though the keyword true
they're doing all that [ __ ] because
their husband doesn't love
her
they're not having sex anymore they're
dry spells he's out at the strip club
all the time
you can't make it generalize everything
but so she spends all her time decanting
her [ __ ] i think so because she has
to feel like she's doing a good job
yes that's me i feel attacked
you are [ __ ] pumpkin spice white
[ __ ]
i'm like listen every time my house gets
clean you better believe i'm not getting
dicks there's just something about
there's just something about naming your
kids hayden braden and kaden that just
feels so organized you know
that's pretty organized yeah you can
live that kaylee life if you want i
might kill texas you can
dude i think deep down inside you want
it because you're so wifey you want to
be live laugh love it's like you're so
[ __ ] wifey
[Laughter]
those type of people that you're
thinking of like you think that that's
the most mentally stable but imagine if
someone put a pillow out of place they'd
flip out if that's not emotional
that's the biggest problem i'm in my
friend's mom is the ultimate live laugh
love type type of lady and my friend
just hated her life yeah they have
control issues yeah
that's why i feel like this conversation
particularly is mentally stable yeah
like everyone's [ __ ] up in their own
weird way yeah yeah this is the outlet
for your mental instability
i wonder to a therapist what is a
healthy mental state for a happy person
a secure attachment i know
is the healthy one where they're just
like i'm okay with me
and i'm okay with you like you you do
you yeah we're doing things for you and
for like like for the sake of doing them
and not for the outcome like where
you're detached from the outcome you're
not doing this like so that one day you
can have blah blah blah you're doing it
for the sake of enjoying the ride more
maybe yeah i wonder if there's anyone
out there that's like yeah i don't
really get no problems i'm cool like
super chill happy and just i probably
want to know what that person's like
probably not very many yeah i just want
to see what it's like you know because i
remember when i went over to my friend's
house and they like they come from a
family that's still together they had
like
hundreds of photo albums throughout the
years and like they're happy and they
have family photos and i'm like
you guys like each other this is weird
like you guys get along like yeah i'm
too too skeptical i'd be like okay no
for real yeah
i was like okay so who in the family is
like a [ __ ] up any like weird uncles
they're like no like
chill no gambling problems no perverts
no like nothing i'm like bored
there's something
wrong somewhere
somewhere and if there's nothing the
wrong thing is that this is boring i
didn't no there's still something wrong
somewhere so i did find something wrong
yeah there's entitlement yeah because
they've never been through any like sort
of trauma or whatever so they never
understood how to deal with people who
have like yeah it's like oh you're
depressed why don't you just be happy
they only see things through this one
lives they can't even imagine yeah
yeah detachment probably because they
don't really get like you're not
grounded if you don't understand how
people but that only affects the other
people like it doesn't even affect them
really yeah it doesn't affect them very
much i guess it affects the something
affects them it does there's no people
that don't have problems of course sure
now let's get into some of these okay
so number one
uh intrusive thoughts people often say
that they have really unpleasant and
sometimes violent intrusive thoughts
this is actually a lot more common than
people think it usually does not mean
that you are violent or disturbed i
relate to we could
kind of an example so i guess my example
would be
um
oh i i talked about this when we went um
on our cabin trip where it's like
sometimes i just think about like the
thought will cross my mind of like i
don't know just getting a knife and
murdering someone that's like really
really like hurt me that has really hurt
me oh
or or not that i would ever do it yeah
yeah i could disturb at myself right
having these thoughts
but yeah i think like that's kind of
along the lines of that something that
we when you think it you're like how did
i just think that yeah what the [ __ ] i
feel like i only have that about like
self-harm thoughts
yeah those two yeah like you ever drive
and you was like wonder if i just yeah i
have those a lot you know yeah i could
literally just like crash this car right
now [ __ ] up like a whole line of people
or like or just myself that's when bill
burr said that in his his comedy i was
like
i [ __ ] relate there isn't a joke
online where it's like the girl's like
i hate you so much i might just kill
myself in front of you and throw off the
whole trajectory of your life [ __ ] see
what happens jesus
yeah
who knows i might just do it damn
i was laughing so hard
there's a she's like i love my life but
i'll do that that's how much i hate you
there's a person that uh i used to know
that said that they would say that
whenever they would see a balcony they
wouldn't want to jump off right yeah and
so they have there's actually a term for
that it's called the call of the void
where it's like these thoughts like if
you're standing on a cliff you're like i
wonder what happens if i just jump so
it's the call of duty they get worried
that they can't stop it
like it's a thing yeah well apparently
it's normal normal you guys i'm trying
to think of what intrusive thoughts that
i've had recently that's what you have
recently or these things do you think
that are more maybe like more when
you're just going through a stressful
time or like hormonal i very frequently
want to melt into the earth and never be
seen again but that's just depression
that's yeah i feel like that's not
intrusive because i just accept that
thought and then move on
yeah well uh i mean i feel like
i always jokingly always say like i hope
you get hit by a bus but not really you
know like not really i don't want that
to happen to you regina george but you
know like somebody was just like ugh hit
by a bus yeah right and you're like wait
i can't believe i said that and then
you're like oh but then now that i put
that in the world
it's my fault yeah exactly the way that
i say that because i'll have those
thoughts too but then i always have to
add it at the end but you come out alive
and un unscathed yeah like you're one
finger like literally nothing wrong
happened to you you just went through
that experience
is it the truth
you just like want them to feel pain and
then but nothing happens or just be
traumatized like you don't have to go
like you're okay still yeah you're
physically you're okay yeah
i know you're the best thank you we love
you
yeah yeah i did
oh okay does this one count um because i
feel like mine are never like towards
other people but like um like things
that i'm more scared of they're more
like self-directed i don't know why but
um like i frequently and this one just
like
stops me in my tracks all the time and
like really it intrudes my day which is
why i feel like it's intrusive as i
think about my cat dying and like i
think about like how i couldn't live
without him and how that'd be so
terrible but it it's gonna happen but
i'm like but please don't let it happen
soon and then i'm like just in this like
flurry for hours i think intrusive
thought could be anything that like
disrupts your day you don't want to
think about this no it's there sometimes
i think about like my dad or yeah just
like something important to me like
going away yeah like why do i keep like
[ __ ] ruminating on this terrible
terrible thing yeah that happened to me
a lot when isaac was born when he was a
newborn
i don't know why i kept having these
thoughts of like a plane crashing down
and like literally only getting him
it literally wasn't tiny dark maybe i
think i did watch the movie around that
time too maybe probably there it is but
yeah like it's your instinctiveness to
protect him you're just thinking about
everything possibly yeah that could
happen it's when he's like cuddling me
right on my face and then like i just
have so much love and i'm just like oh
my god i love him so much and then i
think about like how he's gonna die yeah
and then i think about how everything in
my life is gonna die and then i just get
really sad oh yeah that's super weird
it's always when i'm having the best
time that these thoughts happen
yeah yeah yeah
for those of you at home that have those
thoughts just think of it like the other
way too like yeah we're all gonna die so
enjoy it and have fun and live the best
life that you can have now i don't give
your pets the best life about me dying i
don't care about me dying
but i care about everything around me
that i love dying yeah
yeah and leaving you behind or just the
fact that they have to die well both
okay but like that i won't have them in
my i'll have to live on without them
yeah
i would rather go first well speaking of
death the second one here it says
mixed or even positive feelings when a
loved one dies after a protracted
illness
especially someone who hung on for a
long time very sick and suffering or an
older relative with dementia there's
often a feeling of relief
at least that's over it's perfectly
normal and doesn't mean you didn't love
that person i think it means you love
them because they're not suffering
anymore yeah yeah
i actually relate to that too too about
my dad actually
like i don't know if my dad is here or
not because he's been missing for
how many years like three years i think
2017 right four years yeah i don't even
like to keep track of how long it's been
but
it's been a long time and but when i
think about like the possibility of him
possibly being dead i actually feel
relieved because i'm like
he's he's had a hard life he's like
closure to it really hard life at least
he's not suffering anymore because he
had he struggled with alcoholism and a
lot of other issues and
i'm like well if he's gone like at least
he's at peace yeah and i feel guilty for
feeling that no
yeah i don't yeah i don't think you
should
yeah because it's like you're wishing
them the best like you want them to be
happy because you love them
and like my grandma had alzheimer's for
10 years and so i felt like i damned
last year yeah before she died and she
was a young grandma too like she became
a grandma at 44 with me i was the first
grandchild and
by the time she actually passed i felt
relieved because
it
it hurts so much
that she didn't remember like there was
it's like all the memories that we had
together got erased by this disease and
it like was really painful to like
see her alive but like be mourning her
while she's still alive basically and
then when she passed it was like i just
got to remember
her as i remember her not like
the her that she ended up as and it was
which is so unrecognizable
and um yeah i felt like uh
like it gave me permission to grieve
almost
and also like i think she's in a much
better place look who cares
who's that franklin yeah glenn what you
doing your heart is here to remind me
yeah cutie i think i felt the same way
when my mom passed for sure like it's
almost like my life finally had like
less of a burden on it just in general
like i was smoking at the time i quit
smoking after she died like there's just
so much
stuff that you're worrying about i was
kind of like a negative
person like like all the time versus
just like some of the times or like when
i joke i'll joke negatively but like i
was literally just always kind of a
negative person and then
just her passing even though it's so sad
and weird to say but like it really took
a burden off of me so much but i don't
feel bad about it because i know exactly
why and it is because she was suffering
and she was causing her children to
suffer like but like not on purpose yeah
it wasn't her fault like you know so
just the ending of suffering is
definitely good and it's okay to to
experience joy at the end of suffering
it may not be joyous that she's dead but
you know like a relief yeah relief at
the end of suffering is okay
kitty
oh there's a kitty coming here
i mean
he does sense emotions he's really good
at like comforting when anyone has
anxiety or emotions yeah
you wanted to come see what we're doing
all day
yeah they've never done this before oh
my god
he's like oh he's like happy new year
everyone pushed his face on my hands you
just had to get that in there dude
sometimes i have intrusive thoughts
about wanting to say happy new year
because it pisses off yeah it's so funny
it'll be april like happy new year yeah
and hang out here
okay
next one
it says i think when people admit that
they sometimes make things up and
they're not sure why sometimes this
spirals into stories they have to keep
up especially teenagers often in the
context of talking about negative mental
health then parents
catch them being happy and they feel
they must feel down to keep up
appearances this is quite sad because
then the low mood becomes reality but
the person is totally convinced they're
faking it when they are actually feeling
quite low yes sometimes the people that
don't understand depression don't get
that like you can
wreck be happy but at the same time
depressed like depression is just a
baseline right and then there's still
moments of your life that are enjoyable
but that doesn't mean you're not
depressed all of a sudden yeah
but i can see you know a kid or a
teenager or something like
having to like kind of this is who i am
and then like kind of having to stick
with it and then it just like becomes a
reality and they're kind of stuck with
it
and then they just kind of do this
self-fulfilling prophecy on it because
they don't want to like
that's kind of be a liar maybe yeah
that's kind of how i felt too when i was
going through like like i have all these
traumas when i was a kid and then i
realized a lot of it affected my life so
when i started therapy i'm like what if
i
fix those traumas and i'm okay then why
not then what have your identities yeah
yeah
i kind of was like that too especially
like when i used stand up as like an
outlet for like really dark depression
[ __ ] and and i felt like i was
good right away like like i was funny
because of how depressed it was and it
was like a lot of self-deprecating jokes
and stuff but then i started like
my life started getting better and i'm
like oh and i went to therapy and i was
like oh no like
i'm not funny anymore like i don't i'm
not funny unless i'm really really
really sad and making turning that
darkness into light and i did have to
bring that up to my therapist because i
was like i don't think i don't know i
think i have to be depressed to like
write stuff
and um and she was like no you just have
never embraced this part like you can
embrace this this part yeah i remember
the therapist that you showed me she
said yeah
trauma plus time equals comedy yeah
that's true i mean think of sitcoms it's
like the characters in a lot of pain
it's just we think it's funny because
the situation is so bizarre or like
silly but they're like actually really
in a lot of pain yeah yeah i think about
this and
um
like as i was reading this it kind of
reminded me of like why maybe sometimes
a teen would
would say that because the part where it
says parents catch them being happy and
they feel they must
feel down to keep up with appearances
like i remember in my teen years
having someone in my life be like oh so
now you're happy
and so i'm like what the [ __ ] that's
just yeah and like it's like not a
mature household yeah and right yeah
when someone's depressed you have to be
crying and sobbing 24 7. right or
they're kind of like mad that they can't
make you happy but you're getting being
happy something new yeah something else
but not them yeah so taking it
personally gross shout out to our
sponsor fanduel and you know what's
coming up regarding fanduel this weekend
are the wild card games
wild card games are some of the most
exciting games because you're watching
teams that are like really fighting to
make it in while you're watching like
number one seed teams like try to keep
their place and like take it away from
them like cowboys sure cowboys cowboys
it is when and wildcard weekend just got
wilder because fan dual sportsbook is
hooking new customers up with 30 to one
enhanced odds when they make a deposit
that means you can bet five dollars to
win
150 bucks on any team to win any wild
card game that sounds great fanduel is
america's number one sports book it's
simple and easy to use they have
generous promotions like the one i just
mentioned it's very safe and secure with
the best in-class customer service that
you could ever imagine and when you win
fanduel will pay you your winnings in as
little as two hours that's so fast
immediately you can get that cash get
that money girl if you already have
fanduel sportsbook fanduel is hooking
all customers up with fifty dollars when
you refer a friend plus your friend will
get fifty dollars that's a lot of doll
hairs a lot of tall hairs that's a good
deal too you're not waging anything and
you're getting fifty dollars so don't
miss your chance to win one hundred and
fifty dollars off a five dollar bet when
you use promo code big mood when signing
up download the fanduel sportsbook app
and use promo code big mood and pick
your wild card team before kickoff
disclaimer you must be 21 and over and
president arizona colorado connecticut
iowa illinois indiana michigan new
jersey pennsylvania tennessee virginia
or west virginia new year's only 10
dollars for deposit required must wager
and designated offer market max bonus
150 bonus for tennessee users were
filled in and credit within 72 hours
tennessee site credit expires 14 days
after receipt restriction supply see
full terms at sportsbook.com.com
gambling problem call 100 gambler or
visit fanduel.com rg in colorado iowa
michigan new jersey pennsylvania
illinois and virginia 1800 next step or
text next step to 53342 in arizona
887-8977 or visit ccpg.org chat in
connecticut 1-809 with it in indiana
tennessee redline
that cat 1-800-889-9789 cured my
depression by the way
you're happy now yes you're happy
you're a happy meow
i know you're so cute okay it was
perfect
you don't have to give me any accolades
for these yeah
forget about it
[Music]
so done with you okay you want to see
how organized my pantry is
decanted hilarious
all right next one it says thinking
about running away from home it's a
common fantasy to have as a teenager oh
dude what about an adult yeah sometimes
like i just want to hide and just go to
another country and start over and see
what happens because you can i can
i mean i kind of did when i moved to
california i just kind of like started
over yeah sometimes i just want to like
move to vegas like somewhere like where
you could do anything yeah
well
luckily uh nikki that is in this time is
already living in oh [ __ ] girl
how you living that's
she's true a new identity now yeah
she doesn't exist anymore
dude i relate to that though like
wanting to run away even now like even
now where do you want to go now i have
some thoughts sometimes like when it's
like really
stressful that's an interesting thought
yeah and i'm like if i could just
escapism escape yeah just hide but then
this baby's with me yeah where would you
go
me yeah
i was just as far as to think like oh i
could live here i would like to go i i
don't my thought doesn't get as far as
actually planning where to go or like
thinking of how i'm going to do it or
like thinking of the possibility like i
don't get to that point that's the fun
part though yeah
[ __ ] live in boston and eat [ __ ]
clam chowder like you don't think
chowder no but it's kind of like um
like those really dark thoughts where
it's like you know what
i think i've had enough of this thing
called life like sometimes like you know
like there's like those thoughts but
then like that's like first level like
service level and then you end up
thinking about like how you're gonna try
to peace out and then like you know like
there's levels like for me with the
runaway thing i don't get to the other
locals oh mine's a treehouse in costa
rica
oh it should be fun but i would have to
have a wi-fi
i'm going to japan yeah i would either
do japan or paris i think i need a beach
for me it'd be a beach if i had to think
about it but also it would be like i'm
disconnected from the world yeah if i'm
running away i don't want to be
connected to the world but i just want
the wi-fi to research things
short-term wise it's more like i just
want to hide in my bed and just pull my
blanket over my head and not deal with
the world for a little bit you know like
sometimes like i just want to hide and
just shut up and just hide in there
those are the floor melt days
i go in the closet oh yeah
melted to the floor i like to feel like
nobody knows where i am in here mm-hmm
like a little like cocoon yeah maybe
it's uh your inner child reverting back
to like wanting the comfort of like
hiding definitely or something
i don't think i've had any of those
feelings of like the hiding thing or
like because i'll still like if i'm
depressed like i'll still watch tv or
i'll scroll the internet or something
like i've never done the like so i
distracted totally blank out yeah i do a
lot of distracting things i i don't just
like blinking i get over stimulated um
well technically like turning off your
instagram is as a way of kind of hiding
from the world turning it off like
getting rid of it or like didn't you
i would like to delete the app from my
phone yeah every now and then hiding but
i would still be like on like like
scrolling the news or something like i
would never like i would still be
distracting myself with the internet at
times too it just wouldn't be like
social media the people that know me on
social media like so i guess it's hiding
in a way but not not like to where i
like leave the internet and i'm in a
dark room
or like just in my bed without my phone
or something like i haven't really done
that yeah yeah i think is that how you
dealt with things when you were younger
too like you just like watched
distracted yeah yeah that's how i dealt
with [ __ ] too in my household like i
would live a different life
in a show or something yeah i wouldn't
try to just disappear
yes i would inject myself into something
else well that it's the same with like
the levels that you're talking about so
that's a different level for me it's
like there's one level where i just want
to be distracted because i'm too
stressed out or whatever and i would do
that like video games especially
um but then there's the level where i
physically feel like i will never stop
crying and i just want to high roll in a
ball and hide under a comforter and
not
have anybody know where i am at all
like i physically want to disappear from
the planet i don't know if i've gotten
to that somewhere like ostrich it just
stick your head in a dirt hole yeah
stand there and also like you know
blankets are really comforting and so
it's just like i just want to feel safe
again and like
okay
but like my physical body doesn't feel
okay right all right next one it says
having an inner dialogue people fear
i'll consider them psychotic this is a
therapist saying i think that's normal
right everyone i actually met someone
who has no inner dialogue what it's the
strangest thing that's weird yeah so
that's a little bit weird she like we
cause she's a streamer also i'm like you
have like do you have a voice in your
head like what is your voice sound like
she's like i don't have she doesn't like
plan out things no like she says it out
loud to go to the store oh i talk out
loud too but there are both nope she
says that they're and out here and so
that's why on her stream like people are
always like she it's it's funny because
she always blurts out exactly what you
know what she wants to say because she
has no inner dialogue at all no
storytelling no nothing in there yeah
and that's so bizarre i can't relate to
that that's really crazy
not really so what's goes on in there
like when you're when no one's talking
when you're in a quiet room i'll have
thoughts but it's not like spoken
thoughts
like i don't know how to describe it
it's like tree bird um
so it's not like it's not spoken
pictures so it's it's kind of pic so i
remember doing i remember looking up an
article one time and there was like a
study or something talking about how
some people they'll just think like
visually like pictures but then other
people like think like only in words or
whatever i think i'm a weird like mix of
that because it's not fully one thing
it's not fully the other thing and
it's sometimes neither i can't describe
it like i don't have um
like do you visualize like say you're
gonna go to the mall tomorrow and you're
really excited about going to the mall
because it's like you're gonna go buy
all the presents like you don't do you
like think forward about things that are
gonna happen but do you like okay like
you're planning out in your head like
right now i'm in the middle of
like i'm about to start this project at
home where i'm redoing the whole closet
and like i'm taking tearing down what i
currently have and i'm putting shelves
up like built up things right
i
because i'm so excited about starting
this project like when i'm laying down
to go to sleep in these past few nights
because i'm so excited about the project
i tried thinking about it and then i
tried like i tried
picturing myself going into the closet
and pulling out the things and like
that's the thing that's how i am too
thinking about like where i'm gonna hang
it and i'm like in the meantime while i
fix the closet but then i get stuck in
like the first like two steps and then
after that like my brain goes somewhere
else oh and i can't finish that thought
oh like i literally haven't
like
mentally visualized me finishing the
[ __ ] closet i always get stuck in the
first couple two hours
and then i go somewhere else and then
that other somewhere else it's not like
pictures and it's not words like it's
just like thoughts like i don't know how
to explain it but the inner dialogue
thing like the inner voice
that [ __ ] was new to me like a few years
ago where i was like wait people
actually hear their voice inside their
head like oh my god like i never really
i've never heard people's voices in my
head too like sometimes i'll hear gina
go are you stupid [ __ ] baby like in
gina's voice and i'm like yeah
yeah i hear don't hear a voice you hear
my own voice yeah i hear my own voice
and then it also comes to like people
who are bilingual it's like do you hear
your own voice speaking spanish or
english when you're thinking to yourself
oh that okay so you just said that it
unlocked a memory when i was living in
mexico and there was like a a time
because i lived there for one year when
i was 15.
and there was this one period of time
where it was like this weird like blend
in my brain where i was forgetting my
english but i didn't know enough spanish
and like i was like [ __ ] i can't
communicate in any language and it was
just like weird but then i started
dreaming in spanish
and then like and then when i was
counting things i started counting in
spanish like if i count i do hear her
voice okay so it's only sometimes it's
really hard i don't know
no i don't think that's not normal
because i have a blend too then because
yeah same with you i've been trying to
pick out the floors in my new house
forever and i'm trying to visualize it
and i'm trying to visualize like what
lighting fixtures if i did pick those
floors would i have to paint the walls
and it's like when you play one of those
design home games where you're like flip
switching out the floors and you're
switching out the wall colors but in my
head and i'm trying to like remember
what i remember about that house while
i'm doing it and then
um but i i don't know if i hear a voice
when i'm doing that it's more visual and
then when i'm doing tasks though around
the house where i'm like okay well then
i have to do this first oh [ __ ] no i
gotta go here first okay so here's what
we're gonna do we're gonna do this and
then this and like i'm planning it out
like
mentally i'm definitely always having
conversations in my head i have like
conversations in my head before they
happen that i think might happen yes i
have i really have conversations that
already happen and i definitely have
shower arguments i'm always people like
thinking about something like talking
yeah
yeah interesting but no wait so never
visual for you like never a picture
i can visualize things but i feel like a
lot of it is uh more like emotions
maybe like feelings or like flashbacks
of like where i was or where i would
like to be
i don't do a lot of like mental mapping
visually of like things i plan out
because like i just kind of do them as
they come but it's more of just an
emotional
like i'm thinking about
um
an argument we had and like we're
sitting in your living room and i'm like
rethinking about that argument i'm like
damn it and then but i'm like in that
i'm like back in your living room again
yeah like thinking how i wish i would
have said that conversation okay
you know but like i don't really like
sit there sit there like mental map out
things like how you're talking about
like with your
floors and stuff like that yeah i think
i really do that i think most of my
thoughts are puzzles like or things with
that i need to find the answers to yeah
i need to know if you guys get this
because this is something that i'm like
is it just me
so if i
if i listen too much to
a
person like let's say i'm watching a
show and it's the same character every
time or it's like um i'm reading a book
and like the auth it's the author's
voice the whole time or um i'm watching
interviews of a specific person i start
thinking in their voice yeah and
everything is in their voice and like i
start saying things the way that they
would say them and the cadence that they
say
okay yeah i remember i watched like the
real housewives of atlanta like i binged
it yeah and in my head my thoughts were
in nina yeah
it's like that was like this is so wrong
on so many levels but her voice just
like
interjected itself into my brain it's
like a channel that's where nene's voice
i was like i definitely can't say this
[ __ ] i really like that one i've never
it was a british accent because uh
because of i was watching misfits i was
like just only watching misfits from the
uk the show and i just kept hearing my
yeah my voice was in the british accent
a british accent wouldn't i was watching
so many beatles interviews yeah and then
i'm like i wish i was from liverpool
everything is coming to me in liverpool
yeah
i've never had that it's always just
been my stupid never wanted to like
mimic something i didn't i don't even
want to mimic it i don't watch it yeah
but it's just like it's it's it's just
there's right it's like a song gets
stuck in your head you can't get it out
it's like that but without an accent
yeah yeah songs get stuck in my head but
i've never had like another like tick
tock like meme shits like you i hear you
like randomly spam off tick tock meme
shits but like they're they've heard so
many times my normal thoughts voice
doesn't change to their voice i just
hear i just keep repeating what they're
saying because it's funny in your voice
oh so it's just like a sound bite
instead of like you sound like instead
of like channeling that character now
through yeah yeah maybe it's your
actress in you maybe but sometimes it's
like
sometimes i have to watch videos of
myself to get back to myself
that's funny before i do my podcast
because i gained personality
she loses herself too much like the
other person i'm like oh no no i've
watched too much of a youtuber before
and then i'm like i'm speaking like that
person now yeah when i used to do
stand-up and i was listening to a lot of
stand-up comedy and if i listened to one
comedian for too long i'd start speaking
in there cadence i'm like no no i can't
i can't do that cadence because it's
like very them i am i pick up people's
like
uh the words like and a little bit
they're saying though they're the way
they speak too that's like
actually voicing it out though but never
in my head but i do notice that i tend
to pick like to to pick up people's
slangs and cadences and voices a lot if
i spend a lot of time with them yeah
that happens to me too yeah sometimes or
if i'm in a conversation too long with
them
and it's the worst when they're very
awkward because then i get very awkward
and they're both just very [ __ ]
awkward
they're like just making fun of me no no
i can't help it it's [ __ ] funny okay
next one
feeling conflicted when a caregiver who
abused them is exposed
faces consequences many express feeling
bad for them because this person abused
them but they also took care of them
provided for them etc i always try to
tell them that what they're feeling is
normal and understandable but that the
abuser needs to face consequences for
what they have done nope can't relate
the abuser has to suffer at all times i
relate to this recently actually oh yeah
wait so what's the
the part that the person's having a hard
time is is like feeling conflicted about
the their abuser facing consequences
yeah you should be happy about it that's
like kind of like that uh what is it
stockholm stockholm kind of feeling
right like a little bit in a way where
it's kind of like oh well they still
took care of me like i don't you know i
don't want them to get hurt that bad nah
can't relate to that at all i'm like
very like hey you know like if you
treating me like [ __ ] i don't care if
you brought me up like yeah i hope you
[ __ ] die yeah like that's what i
thought i would feel too but then like
when this recent thing happened
i ended up finding myself
feeling sorry for them
and and like i had always thought like
you know what
[ __ ] this person they hurt me they
abused me when i was a child like just
the worst right and like my whole life i
had always pictured like i just want to
see them burn and rot and [ __ ] them like
suffer [ __ ] you you traumatize me
but then recently i hear like some of
the stuff that they're going through and
like how they're they feel they're not
good
like like they feel bad for what they
did to me and
and then i started feeling bad for them
where i'm like
wait this feels weird well i think it's
like even just because you know how bad
it was and you're like it's weird that
another human has to realize and
confront the fact that they are an
absolute piece of [ __ ] like you almost
feel like even just removing yourself
from the fact that you're the victim
it's like imagine realizing that you did
something so depraved yeah and having to
live with it yeah like that is a tough
like pill to swallow like when you
realize you are the abuser
right like that's really hard and
probably very damaging to their psyche
so you're just like whoa like i'm sorry
that's
you [ __ ] up like that's the terrible
feeling yeah you know because the thing
too like i had never known that
this person
some like their parent
found out about what this person did to
me
and literally on their their parents
death bed
they were like i know what you did to
tiff
and every time that they think about
their parent yeah they always think
about what they did to me and then like
the constant hearing about that i'm like
oh man like that [ __ ] sucks like i
don't know it's just it's really
conflicting it's just yeah i had it i
was on the other end of that because i
remember i got to confront the people
who abused me
um it was my grandparents and i
confronted them finally as an adult
and
they denied it the whole entire time and
so they said i was making it up and said
oh you just saw it in movies and you're
making things up i'm like dude i am 30
years old they're 29 i'm not making this
[ __ ] up and so they denied it
and
it's like i was like that's why i don't
ever feel bad because see that's
different because they haven't realized
that they're a piece of [ __ ] yeah so um
the last they're not suffering yeah
mm-hmm the last thing i told him the
wife was
um you know what like i don't really
care if you accept it or not or
apologize i just want you to remember
i want you to remember that every night
when you go to bed next to him know that
you're sleeping next to a man that likes
to touch children and i hope you never
forget that i hope it follows you to
your dead i hope like you realize the
whole family knows about it and it's and
you suffer and you
die of embarrassment you know because
it's like
sure i mean maybe later on i'll be like
oh i feel bad it's like you didn't feel
bad during you know i had to suffer my
whole life for
your few moments of pleasure you know so
i don't i can't really relate to this
it's like it's but it also comes down to
like how bad the the crime was
you know like i'm not gonna wish
terrible things upon someone who simply
just pissed me off and we're not friends
anymore but this was such a huge thing
that i can't feel bad for these people
like i never will yeah i feel like they
have no remorse and they're getting i
think that's probably the biggest
like key component here with with that
because
my like i said all these years like my
whole freaking life like never once did
this person because they would they
actually denied it too like when they
were confronted with it when i was
younger they denied it they tried making
up some excuse like some [ __ ] and
i'm like what the [ __ ] like [ __ ] you die
like [ __ ] die but then now that they
actually realize what they did they're
they're trying to
like
be remorseful or whatever not that they
ever came to me and i wouldn't want them
to come like that's conflicting right
like i don't want you i don't want to
give you the satisfaction of apologizing
to my face
i still don't want that
but i still kind of feel bad that you're
suffering i don't know it's [ __ ]
weird it's because you have empathy
mm-hmm you're a human being that has
empathy yeah yeah and you don't you
don't want others to suffer which is
very healthy yeah
[Laughter]
if their parents told them straight up
on their deathbed that you know i know
what you did to gina and whatever and
they suffer and think about that for the
rest of their lives i would be on cloud
nine you know like i'd be so happy like
good you know
i think there is an element of happiness
yeah i have to like there is an element
of like
good yeah but then there's that part of
you that emphasizes yeah that's what i'm
saying too is like yeah i agree with you
i'm not saying like right not to feel
like yeah
you want it to balance out like you want
you caused me so much pain i want you to
feel even an ounce of that you know
but then what she's saying is that like
now that this person's just in a dark
hole suffering that you kind of feel sad
for them like they're like a little like
they're they're like an old dog that's
going to die right and now you're just
like oh like
you know i feel bad for you but
i'm not gonna help you but right so
weird so conflicting well apparently
it's normal so if you're feeling this
way it's okay
uh okay next one a therapist said i've
had patients describe their imposter
syndrome in great detail that one
genuinely surprised when i say everyone
feels like that myself included
something i don't think everyone feels
like that narcissist sure as hell don't
[ __ ] that's true yeah and also i
think more women feel it than men yeah
men are more likely to think they're
qualified for something that when they
have when they're ready to seek it out
and women are more likely to feel like
they're not qualified when they're
overqualified interesting yeah oh yeah
there's that pay gap oh yeah yeah
because women aren't willing to
negotiate as hard as men are and they
need to feel like they're experts before
they start to negotiate that hard
whereas men already think they got it
like
huh yeah and so like i was so afraid
when when i was when i first was working
in a corporate world right before i left
and then came back i never like knew to
negotiate my salary i didn't think that
was the thing i was like what if they
tell me they don't want to give me the
job anymore you know like what if i ask
for something and then they just take
all of it away and then which is so
ridiculous yeah right so then when i got
my job this time i for sure i was like
yeah i'm gonna negotiate what do you
mean like that's that's a part of it so
it's just
the imposter syndrome is something that
you
all probably will have to deal with like
everyone is gonna have to deal with but
like once you kind of realize it a
little bit more and then realize how
other especially like a lot of men not i
wouldn't say all i don't think all men
are that confident but a lot of guys
don't give a [ __ ] they're just like i'll
take whatever give me it all i deserve
all of it yeah whatever you know i don't
know if that's a genuine feeling for
them or if they just act that way yeah
but like we don't have it well it also
makes it harder too and there are actual
men out there that say oh this woman
didn't deserve what they had yeah it was
right handed to them well and if you
think about the way that boys and girls
are traditionally raised like um every
time the
male is like proud of his
accomplishments it's like yes like you
should feel proud and like you should
like
be confident but if a girl displays
overconfidence or they're like seen as
bragging or they're being bossy
and so they're kind of told to stand
down a lot yeah and so as we grow up we
thought oh the good the right thing to
do is to stand down you know you don't
you don't speak up you don't act bossy
you don't
you know speak your mind because it was
so shunned growing up yeah and then
something i learned in the last few
years too is like that emotion is even
worse for like black women in particular
because they have that like angry
angry black woman stereotype i'm like i
can't even imagine like because being a
woman and like trying to assert yourself
is already hard enough yeah and then add
that like angry black woman [ __ ] on top
of it and you can never get anything
already a bias yeah geez all right next
one at therapy said
uh when their patients when they regret
having kids or weren't instantly
attached to their child when they were
born it's a lot more common than people
think but the subject is extremely taboo
and is not
often discussed i [ __ ] told you happy
all moms and dads don't even want those
babies but you won't admit it
was that about not them wanting them
it's about regretting says the one with
a baby inside yeah
no i'm like yeah i'm like how come you
never
ever hear anyone say yeah i kind of
regret having kids a little they do like
never [ __ ] tell you oh yeah
yeah i know like yeah you can't even
like say we're adults though we're
behind closed doors you don't want to
get jealous yeah and what if the kid
found out somehow that you said that
yeah like what if they found what if
it's okay like what if it's like if i
was talking to nikki and he's like i
kind of regret having this kid i'd be
like yeah i think it's okay to have
those feelings but i understand why it's
taboo to talk about because if it ever
got back to the kids
like i would have to talk to my
therapist today about how like even
knowing that i was in oops i have to
talk about sometimes because i'm like
you know there were people that
didn't want me to be born you know and
like i wasn't planned so there's if i
had known that after i was born
people my one of my parents was like i
regret it and i kind of you know but you
can work out for a little while um like
it's traumatizing to the kids yeah and
you can feel that way it's totally valid
for that the parent to feel that way i'm
not taking that away but i can
understand why they wouldn't talk about
it right because if if that kid ever
heard that that's how would they ever
hear that devastating and it's not just
that it's you yourself like as like
admitting as a parent you don't even
want to admit that you have those
feelings because you just feel so
horrible about even having those
feelings but doesn't it make it harder
though for people to be able to say that
like maybe i don't want to have like
everyone's like you have to have kids
it's the best thing ever and then when
other people are like well i don't know
if i want then there's people that are
pressured everyone has to have kids
because it's so great it makes your life
so great and then no one's going to be
willing to say like actually i think
maybe i could have not had kids and had
a good life and like let other people i
feel like they feel like it's okay to
not have kids i've heard uh parents say
that in subtext like they say it this
way where they're like like it's really
hard work like they're like you gotta
really want
like they'll say it like that so it's
like they're not saying they regret it
but they're like
they you know there's a lot of great
moments but it's really hard work and
you have to really want it yeah the way
that i would express these emotions um
to
like my friends
um even
like
even isaac has asked me to like did you
ever like regret having me because you
were so young whatever like the way that
i express it is like
i have never regretted having you like
you've been the greatest blessing in my
life you gave me purpose you gave me a
reason to live like
not you
the only thing that i wish i could have
changed is the timing i wish i would
have given myself a time to grow up i
was still a child when i had you and
you've had to
endure
the
the trials and tribulations of me
growing up to be a parent yeah at the
same time as you growing up so that's
the only thing i wish i could have
changed but as when i was when isaac was
first born and as being like a teen mom
man that [ __ ] was rough like having
emotions and i'm like
why did i get pregnant and i'm like why
did i do this now like what was i
thinking i was only 17 what the [ __ ] was
i thinking like thinking that i was
ready for this and like and i just had
these like horrible like it would eat me
up inside how bad it felt to
feel those feelings because i'm like but
it's not about myself baby though no
it's just about the circumstance no and
we get that because we're adults but i'm
saying if the kid heard that
that's cuts a little deeper and might be
something they have to deal with later
because
it's like you're hearing your own parent
and you it's hard not to take that
personally you know even the way i've
explained it to isaac after the fact
after because now it's like i can't put
the toothpaste back in the yeah
i see how that has affected him because
then he'll say things like
well mom if like you know if you had me
later
um it wouldn't be me because like i
explained to him about ovulation and all
that stuff like it would be a different
egg like my like the egg that's yeah
yeah but then he's like and then he's a
teenager
and he'd be like and then my dad like he
makes me a different sperm
and it would still be you because that's
just the physical
told forms and he didn't enter that yet
that's what i told him too but then he
was like but you wouldn't have been with
my dad like eventually or whatever
because like we we broke up when he was
nine months old so soul stays the same
yep that's what i said i'm like it would
still be you're like i want you as a
person still i just wish i could have
waited a couple more years yeah like
even if physically that wouldn't or even
like i mean yeah and then just maybe uh
choosing like or just siding with the
partner that i would end up with and
like not just be all willy-nilly when
i'm 17.
just be all like yeah i'm ready to be a
parent like oh my god
how naive poor young tiff well it
definitely shaped
him as like
we all have something that happened when
we were younger
scot-free yeah and
no like i think as he gets older he'll
he'll realize like what you know what
jess is saying where it's like it
doesn't have it's not related to him and
i think he worded it great it's just not
a child's understanding you know
um
because i think that's exactly how my
parents probably were they were my mom
was 22 and my dad was 24 but my dad
wanted to be a pro baseball player and
like they basically dropped everything
to raise us and have kids and like my
dad went back to college and then they
were both working full-time and stuff
and um i could as an adult see how that
is really stressful especially that they
were in like
like starting wage jobs you know like
they were working around the clock and
then not having time for each other
and then everything was about raising
kids and that's super super stressful
but as a kid all you're seeing is like i
never see my parents
then when i see them they're sometimes
they're fighting or they don't really
seem like they want to be around me or
whatever and then it's like it goes
inside you and then later you have to
deal with it but it didn't mean they
didn't love me i feel very loved by them
like i feel like they gave me the best
possible life they were only working
around the clock to support us you know
but
you kind of just pick up what your
parents are feeling regardless and then
if it's actually confirmed verbally
you're like oh my god my mom doesn't i
don't think i got any of that
i mean to be honest like i know that i
was not like i i was kind of a burden on
my parents but i like and even if they
were like yeah i kind of wish that we
didn't like have you at the time or
whatever like i don't think that would
bother me because it's like i'm older
now i guess but but even when i was
younger i don't think i that traumatized
me like the thought of like oh like i
was unplanned that never hurt me no it
didn't hurt me when i was a kid it's
like it's now later like why do i always
feel like less than you know it's like
then you
dig back into like the root of like what
you subconsciously picked up as a child
so like it ends up coming out later like
i didn't realize all of this till way
later yeah i don't know i never noticed
any of that like knowing that i was
unplanned or like maybe possibly even
unwanted i don't think i was necessarily
unwanted but just definitely yeah and i
was like i don't think that
that didn't stick with me so i wouldn't
say that that is going to traumatize
every kid because like that's the last
thing that i think that i'm saying that
that's the reason why people don't want
to talk about it because like they think
it's going to hurt them yeah yeah
exactly and admitting that you you feel
like i don't think you would admit that
to the child but i feel like it's okay
to talk to your friends about it
yeah some parents do we'll just write
out be like you are a mistake you know
there's a piece of [ __ ] like matilda
parents so they don't want to be that
parent yeah but no i think you you
should be able to have mature
conversations with your friends and
family though and be like yeah i have
postpartum i'm not enjoying this i kind
of wish i didn't do it but you know i
signed up for it i'm going to do it and
it's okay mm-hmm mm-hmm that's okay to
say that it's very common yeah yeah it's
okay to be able to say that sometimes
maybe it's easier if you can get that
out because it's almost like a monkey on
your back right like you're carrying
this burden of like oh my god i did
something that i regret and i can't tell
anyone i have to pretend like i love it
it's just like maybe if you just say it
once and then you'll just be like okay i
got that off my chest but i'm still down
for this [ __ ] journey and i'm still
going to do it
yeah i think like people can carry that
burden too for sure i think that that's
why therapy is really great because yeah
it is the unleash the venting out and
being able to process all of those yeah
taboo feelings that you feel too
unsafe to say
in your real life exactly okay and now
this one says
feeling lonely and having only a few
friends social media gives us the skewed
perception that a lot of people have
tons of friends and are always doing
stuff that's not real life though and
everyone feels lonely sometimes everyone
goes through phases where they feel like
they have no one or goes through friend
breakups
completely normal people feel bad about
it i don't have any friends i never see
any of my friends and i actually keep
moving to the state yeah so there's
actually
nice i sat through [ __ ] 14 seasons of
the big bang theory just feel like i
would have friends which is awful
maybe that's why you don't have friends
because like the big bang theory i
didn't like it until i felt so lonely
that none of my friends would ever hang
out i don't i oh man you know those like
sometimes online i see pictures of
weddings with like 12 bridesmaids yeah
but they're not being 14 they're not
close i can't do that man i can't do it
that that's
just stresses me out
like having a big group like that's like
that is tired they're not close to those
girls but yeah but that's still a lot of
socializing with so many girls
don't really like hanging out with
people yeah they just care about like
how everything's gonna look my old
roommate she was one of those girls that
loved having her friends around all the
time to the point where she was always
on the phone with a friend at all times
speakerphones going through the house
like yeah like you're just always
talking or even when they're not doing
anything there's always someone in your
ear
and i was like how do you
how do you think it's exhausting
yeah you're so scared of being alone
even for five minutes possibly can you
imagine her just having to sit in an
island by herself she would probably
want to kill herself yeah but she can't
just like sit with her own thoughts
she's like she's one of those like i'm
sorry she was one of those like they
love to go out and party all the time
it's always a girls group and they dress
the same all the time
that's how my cousin is oh man yeah
she's that same big group of girlfriends
since high school
that's a lot how do you maintain that
yeah there's a lot of effort yeah but
also
like that specifically because you're
actually seeing the effort that's that's
a lot but also like people like talk
about us for example like you know us
having a whole bunch of friends that
they have seen on camera and it's just
like a big old group of people and it's
like
yeah there there are connections there
but it doesn't mean it's like that 24 7.
yeah
even within the four of us like we only
see each other once a month and when i
see them i'm like i can't believe it's
been a month already
it just goes by so fast it's not like
we're intentionally not trying to keep
up with yeah or whatever but it's just
that's how adulthood is and i think it's
hard for younger people to realize that
because of the fact that all their whole
their entire life is just either school
like friends maybe like a like a
whatever like minimum wage job and just
friends yeah friends is your whole life
you feel like that in your 30s yeah you
got like your spouse and then your
family like your kids and then their
families and like you're planning
holidays and the holidays keep coming up
like left and right and then you got to
work and you got to organize your work
life and there's a work balance thing
and happening and then you've got to
organize your pantry
all your laundry detergent
though to point out though because like
in a group like ours right like at one
point our group was probably like 20 30
deep yeah like and then we you would
people would watch us be on vacations or
like doing activities together or
something but like that's once
four or five people per group are like
actually close like the whole group of
30 is not all close
but then they
the perception is that everyone is super
close to each other with when it's
really like this five are close those
six are close those four are close yeah
yeah then we're all kind of like
generally on the same basic level but
it's not that's not real and i'm sure a
lot of other you know
youtube groups are like that too or like
even in sororities and stuff i'm like
i'm sure it's like three of the girls
are actually really close and the other
12 like they all have their own little
factions inside of it just
brought together by some thing yeah but
it's not like that yeah so if you feel
like you're a loser because you don't
have 12 friends like that's not real
like that's not really how it really is
yeah and plus it's a lot cheaper during
holidays
i mean and there should there's value in
deep friendships that are like just
fewer but but deeper yeah
because i don't i don't think i could
water that many plants yeah like yeah
seriously friendships to water yeah yeah
like in our big group it was you're
right there was only a few that was like
super like there's
in that huge group that we had i've only
been over to like four people's houses
yeah you know so
yeah we weren't that crazy close you
don't have to have a ginormous group of
friends to feel validated yeah i'm a
very like
uh what is it a low maintenance friend
yeah super luminous
too yeah you wanted me once a month and
i'm good yeah yeah
same same we're snake plants we're snake
plants
yeah but i like a little more water but
i don't know yeah
the most high
maintenance water but not too much
oh god no for real but anyway thank you
guys so much for watching hope you
enjoyed this episode
and make sure to leave us a thumbs up
comment down below what are some things
that you feel like you might not be
normal about because then maybe you'll
find out a lot of us have the same
thoughts and buy something buy something
from our sponsors but yeah support it
support treat yourself treat yourself
support this show by supporting us
through our support the show by
supporting yourself i love you go to
therapy oh god yeah
yeah i love you bye
[Music]
you